bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovi dire sono famigie oggi siano
tornati su unboxing oggi ragazzi come
potete vedere ci sono un sacco di pacchi
perché sono i parchi della valle
comunque sia adesso dovremo de scatola
rli visto che non so mai cosa c'è dentro
cosa ci mette dentro questa buona
ragazza e spero e prego che non sia
niente di strano
direi che possiamo cominciare con boxing
ai ragazzi passiamo alla prima il primo
pacco perché oggi ce ne sono mille non
potevi fare un patto delle racchie
dell'attrice pensato è però è difficile
vabbè dai facciamo primo parco la sede
scatolare oggi magari senza sfasciare
tutto
sto cercando di capire poi a lo capisco
dopo a cose o grazie no cosa sei pazza
cose per diventare famosi nella pittura
e questo va bene riscatto liamo senza
sfoderare le cose abbiamo 24 set
color acrylic paint di oggi non so cosa
sta scartando cioè la puntata di strani
ambo xvi allora 24 colori acrilici che
sono mamma mia ke bello eh beh allora io
faccio schifo a disegnare qualsiasi cosa
ma questa è bellissima come cosa
allora qui ecco questo a questo posso
immaginare che cosa non sapevo ma questo
no è una sedia dell'ikea non penso che
questa roba credo di aver capito che
questa sia la base per sorreggere la
tela io mi sto chiedendo veramente 16 ma
io non devo montare questa roba ma
limitato da ma non impossibile eppure in
pole a croce nel senso che ci sono
restrizioni in polacco ragazzi che non
sono montare le anche le sedi dell'ikea
che non mi fate montale cavalletto della
teva quel chiodi cribbio abbiamo davanti
e dietro mi siano colori con coloristi
ma dietro dietro questo qua in mezzo c'è
il pareggio
ok sì però non vale che tu non fa niente
poi all'ora e io ho passato cinque anni
del liceo a nel laboratorio di chimica
erano vincolo poteva lavorare in quattro
che non ho mai neanche ha preso la penna
ma non perché sono stati grato perché io
non capisco un cazzo e le cose secondo
me sei sfaticato al che non ti ci metti
nemmeno non ti impegni questo è quello
che ci sono i miei genitori
durant rilassati un po che sei tutto
mamma mia ma chi stai spaccando
ammontare questa cosa non mi hai fatto
lavoro così fa di maiano
la mini ci siamo mi chiamo si mettendovi
a tutte le cose che ho utilizzato per
fare il cavalletto e la cavalletta
tela che è venuta benissimo
ho io questo lo vendo quante per il dio
lo vendo proviamo a vedere se la nostra
invenzione funziona su reti la prima la
tela questo a favore della mia mamma mia
meno male che esiste youtube è
leggermente storto aspettato è giusto
l'inquadratura seggio adesso
ok io vorrei ascoltare questa situazione
molto strana gente giurano mancato
niente di così strano nella mia vita
il menù è la mandina ancora più strada
un tocco di un tocco di che non capisco
grazia succedendo però vabbè web si
guarda del conad
ma non è un placement no no però poi per
lo bianco piacere nessuno bianca sono
una studentessa dell'accademia di belle
arti di brera che oggi sarà molto da
insegnare ok piacere lorenzo chi l'ha
votata dopo di materiali questo qualcuno
che ho trovato io nei pacchi grazie a
fare una domanda al volo che questo
punto un modello a ok vi devo immaginare
anche chi ce li sogna o poi togliere il
trono gay possono togliere il pelo ma
non mi immaginavo soprattutto questa
output incredibile dovrà riportarlo è
esattamente così come ogni minimo
dettaglio
devo fare su tela quello che vedo esatto
mi ha dato anche vi spiega che ci ai
tatuaggi addosso e quello del fatto
va bene possiamo cominciare bene grazie
ecco questa cosa in un piatto da questa
è una cosa da studiare non ho mai capito
perché bisogna indossare questa cosa
attualmente chi lo beve il gol di sì
come cielo che vorrei parlare francese
ma abbiamo preferito a quindi non c'è
una logica nel senso di pete volo che ti
piace
nient'altro per dipingere il santo ci
sono le regole compaia sentimento oppure
deve seguire le regole questo è il primo
di troppo tesa ok andiamo al sentimento
allora per dipingere quest'uomo qui devo
dedurre anche che bisogna mischiare i
vari colori per creare il colore della
pelle meno male che sia andato a
zanzibar dove casey andato scaroni
perché c'è un cuore molto molto
abbronzato quindi mietti semplice usare
questo secondo me questo fa mixato un
telo di questo mamma mia ragazzi il
primo esame l'abbiamo passata casa tipo
cosa noi diciamo che in questo la
ricchezza essere confezionata quali ma
poi spero soprattutto che tu non abbia
visto come montata la
che a quella roba di pesare questa è la
salsa rosa quella di gamberi allora
tentati questo si fa tentativo per
capire se il colore giusto
procediamo questa roba parte la tattoo i
che è il tanto c'è spazio a lui non deve
fare niente lui non può dire niente
perché il modello da vogliono puoi
regalare la t link alta esatto se questa
sarebbe stato meglio metterti steso sul
divano
così come si comincia una difesa come si
comincia allora si parte tutto dal
bacino
se noi non serie dall'altro bisogna
farle
benvenuti su un box in questa parte qua
tutte le curve anche grazie grazie
chi con il capodanno quello sentimento
sentimento misto artistica minuto sta
roba che costa milioni sempre possiamo
fermarci quanto prendere modelli bianca
scusa 35 euro l'ora 4 no no va bene così
che un essere umano qualche una gara la
dinamica sembra un gargoyle e francese
gargoyle e cappello bello grazie sentito
insieme abbiamo finito mancano in quanto
non ho mai fatto il rosso era sulla
schiena è veramente bianca sono
veramente contento di averti conosciuto
ma lei non c'è nudi culo poi sono una
finta di dinosauri dovrebbero essere
dinosauri ma sono solo delle
rappresentazioni di dinosauri però
ginocchio è non glielo rai che non l'ho
visto tra l'altra gamba è un po più
piccola indietro
aiutalo ti prego prima come faccia la
gamba di legno dai dai quindi abbiamo la
figura la presentazione della figura del
mio amico manca chiarezza di goro lungo
hai un gusto proprio arsizio dobbiamo
fare qua del dei tatuaggi perché lui è
un po colorato penso se tutte le si fa
più indietro fatti grigie appositamente
13 gennaio con sedi in france legge
gesù è un artista di statisti manca solo
una cosa perché per essere un vero
artista mi sa che il cappellino ma anche
aprirsi maas naturelles da firme in
black
les jeux sont se la vita sì perché non
ho chiuso la mancava tutto va bene
vorrei prendere questo e avvicinarti a
lui ci vedo bene ragazzi cosa ne
facciamo di questo spenderemo nella mia
dimora lo vuoi appendere a casa tua al
salone un quadro avrai un quadro appena
sei serio serio perché non è poi li
faremo un blog di dove lo apprendiamo
interrotto da ragazzi io sono seriamente
sua pratica si soddisfatto perché
pensavo sarebbe uscito molto peggio e
questo la dice lunga su come dipingere
ragazzi questo era unboxing di pittura
penso sia l'episodio più strano mi abbia
mai registrato quei morti ad es
da quando faccio un box in questo
l'episodio peace strano in assoluto io
concluso perché la situazione del genere
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come dice che è piaciuto se non erano le
canne piace anche vari social che
cominciate descrizione sono stata questi
discrete vi è né come sempre ci vediamo
[Musica]